[Aplausos]
[Música]
luego unos 53 y tengo pasos de 30
centímetros eso me hace una mujer
chaparrita con pasos pequeños cuando yo
era niña mi abuelo me abrazaba y mi hija
tan chula tan pequeña con sus manitas
con sus piecitos ni kaká ve dónde queda
el problema cuando entré en la primaria
las demás niñas me querían molestar
porque yo era la más pequeña entonces
regresé con mi abuelo y le dije es bueno
o es malo sea blando ser pequeño
seguirme ahí pues lo más maravilloso y
yo me lo creí así es que el día que hubo
una niña más pequeña que yo lloré porque
yo no iba a estar enfrente de la tele a
los 18 años mi mamá falleció y apretarle
que pongo el pelo duro mi hermana mayor
mi tío jesús y chincha me apoyaron para
seguir estudiando y poder hacer lo que
más me gustó desde ahora en navidad de
2013 en la platicando en la sala de la
casa mi tío me pregunto a mi primo que
va a ser distinto
y yo le dije tales turnos voy a hacer
oración y no olvidar la evaluación y
como a la media hora regrese de cristian
sé lo que voy a hacer
voy a ir alegres
y medio con esos ojos de arriba a abajo
mejor no eres el negativo y yo elegí yo
sé que no lo son pero tampoco soy un
producto terminado y estoy en constante
cambio y puedo preparar mi cuerpo en mi
mente para estarles así si el recibo
empecé con toda la actitud en el pse con
mi entrenador retamos antes y le lleva
este ese plan él preparó su plan todo
muy padre pero me caigo del techo de mi
casa y me hago un accidente en la
rodilla entonces empieza el
entrenamiento junto con rehabilitación
por un año y medio aproximadamente
después de sean en medio de mucho
trabajo pues llegó la fecha y fui con
reclamos anchos otra vez
y de qué tal que ya mañana me voy antes
que tomaba el sigue el avión el
siguiente día el me abrazo muy fuerte me
cobija de ahora en adelante no la van a
llevando músculos la va a llevar su
corazón ya actual otro día me fui
dallas en londres
nepal india después de aproximadamente
56 horas de viaje me recibió me guía una
pala pudimos saber que a la agencia de
defender ismo ver lo que tiene estaban
con lo que me hace falta lo que me hace
falta comprar pagar lo que hace falta y
el entrenamiento y toda la información
que me tienen que dar siguiente día
tomaba el vuelo de katmandú a glück la
donde es el aeropuerto más peligroso del
mundo porque está a dos mil metros al
nivel del mar y está en la montaña ese
no es inseguridad es solamente la
posición del aeropuerto llegamos ahí
pues yo a caminar el primer día el
primero de los dos el primero y el
segundo día no fueron a maravillosos con
este día porque me empezó a decir oye
y si mejor te regresas antes de partir
que perdiste tienes unos pasitos fáciles
no me hace llegar
y yo me aguantaba entonces el segundo de
ganarme no lo necesitaba esta es la
última vez que tú tratas de quebrantar
no me voy a regresar
este es mi sueño y yo lo voy a lograr
entonces pues no esperaba que yo pueda
conocer hay menos mujeres
y en donde él dio gracias a dios
entonces ya no me volvió a decir nada
pero el dolor era el mismo y el
cansancio y todo por ella no me estaban
fastidiando entonces para el segundo día
íbamos llegando a un pueblo que se llama
nam y pues nomás se veía el horizonte
íbamos caminando las montañas y no se
veía nada dónde podemos llegar
hicimos una vuelta así como a la derecha
y de repente aparece el pueblo precioso
pero lleno de polvo
y yo me preguntaba por qué está bien de
forma y le pregunté antillas porque este
vídeo porque entonces no quería hablar y
no quería hablar mi violencia bueno lo
que pasó pues resulta que había que
acababa de don terremoto yo estaba muy
cansada y el mental que vamos a otro
pueblo el que no no no no aquí nos
quedamos entonces yo agarré mi maleta
les estaba se llama un cuarto
y él me de tú mismo sabes que a partir
de este momento no te puedes tomar una
pastilla para el dolor y yo porque no
porque si te tomas una pastilla para el
dolor te va a am se puede esconder la
enfermedad de la altura y después no nos
vamos a dar cuenta que tiene que se te
llenan los pulmones de agua y en menos
de una hora pero que puede poner yo que
yo estuve de acuerdo para problemas que
yo me tomaba hasta seis aspirinas
diarias por el dolor de la rodilla
derecha por el esguince entonces a
partir de ese momento cada paso me dolía
así que de ahí seguimos caminando
todavía varios días más
el un día antes de llegar nos
encontramos unos franceses italiano
francés inglés alemán croatas y unos
australianos todos de más de un 80
y ya faltando 500 metros para llegar
pero alrededor de 3 horas de camino
ellos se nos adelantaron no sé por qué
porque el plan era que nosotros
saliéramos primero y empezó a caminar
todo apurada y que me encuentro
semestral australianos y respire
caminaron unos pasos y se detenían y yo
con toda la actitud muy y con toda la
energía en realidad con el ciclo no
sabía que era pero los adelante a todos
y primero y le pregunté a mi día oye qué
pasó porque yo los hablaste a todos pues
que de tu altura hay más oxígeno
y una vez más mi abuelo tenía razón es
maravilloso ser pequeño con
determinación y disciplina se pueden
lograr las metas
camine 12 días y así soy la primera
chihuahuense y llegar al everest bay con
5.364 metros mido unos 53 y tengo pasos
de 36 minutos gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]